- [Man] Oh boy, c'mere! (kissing noises)
- [Woman] Lunie, come on. Come on.
(upbeat music)
- Luna's pretty fair with
her love, like, you know
she always makes sure that
if she's cuddling one of us,
that she'll take a break
and go visit the other one.
- [Woman in Blue] That's
Molly's dog, Elsa.
- [Woman in Grey] We both
have very different roles,
I think, so.
- I think Molly makes all the rules.
- Like the fun aunt that
always shows up with candy.
- Yeah, I give her scraps of my food
and play with her on the floor.
- You give her scraps of your food?
- No, I mean, no.
- [Son] Who does she love more?
Definitely me.
- [Father] I would have to disagree.
I think she definitely loves me more.
- She sleeps right next to me.
- That's because you smell like her.
- [Daughter] Her, forever.
- Me.
- They are stuck to her like glue.
Anywhere she goes they trail behind her.
She goes to the bathroom
and they wait at the door.
(upbeat music)
- [Husband] Luna, come
here! (kissing noises)
Come here, sweetheart.
Good girl.
C'mon.
- Brittany!
- Like really?
- Rita come over here.
- Rita!
- Rita Rita Rita.
- Here Rita, Rita!
- Ri, Ri, Ri!
- Oh no no no.
- Stay, stay.
- C'mere. (clapping)
Luna.
- Yes, yes..
- C'mere buppus.
Oh!
- Rita, Rita!
- Rita.
- Rita, this way, this way, Rita!
- C'mon. (kissing noises)
Stay.
- Off to a great start.
- That's not staying!
Turn, Rita!
- Rita, Rita, Rita!
- Lay down.
- Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Ah ha, don't have anything!
- Luna.
- Luna...
- I'm gonna go, bye bye!
- C'mere, c'mere sweetheart.
- Bye bye!
(bell dings)
Awwwwww.
- Oh boy.
- [Woman] Pretty much what I expected.
- Rita, Rita, Rita,
Rita, Ohhhh! (bell dings)
- Hey cutie, mwa!
- [Father] Rita, that's a betrayal.
- [Mom] Come here, my boy,
come here! (bell dings)
- Well.
- [Woman in Blue] Come here! No!
- I was not that surprised
that she picked him.
She's very much a Daddy's girl.
She follows him around.
- And it wouldn't have
mattered either way.
- Yeah, we know she loves us both.
- I felt kind of cheated.
I still think she loves me more.
- Elsa didn't choose either of us.
She just decided to run away.
Yeah, we're not surprised.
She does love freedom.
- I love you the most.
- That's all that matters,
that's all that matters.
(upbeat music)
- This is what it takes.
- This is the only way
that she'll stay in place.
- You're a big baby.
A big baby.